量子情報と計算の理解へようこそ。私はJohn Watusで、IBM Quantumで教育担当テクニカルディレクターをやっている。
これはシリーズの第13回目のレッスンで、第4ユニット、つまり最終ユニットの最初のレッスンだ。テーマは量子エラー
訂正だ。量子コンピューティングは、効率的な古典的アルゴリズムが知られていない計算タスクに対して、効率的な解決策を実現する可能性を持っている。
そして、そのようなアルゴリズムはおそらく存在しないだろう。しかし、私たちが望むような大規模な量子計算を実装するには、非常に大きな課題が
克服されなければならない。その大規模な量子計算がいつか実現できることを願っている。
問題の核心は、量子情報が極めて壊れやすいということだ。文字通り、見るだけで壊してしまうことがある。
だから正しく動作させるためには、量子コンピュータは保持している量子情報を
周囲の環境から極限まで隔離する必要がある。しかし同時に、量子コンピュータ自体が私たちに
この量子情報に対して非常に精密な制御を提供しなければならない。それには適切な初期化、正確で信頼性の高い
ユニタリ演算、そしてもちろん測定を行う能力も含まれる。計算の結果を実際に得るためにね。
これらの要件の間には明らかな緊張関係がある。量子コンピューティングの初期には、量子情報の壊れやすさが
不正確さと環境ノイズの両方に対する脆弱性と相まって、最終的には
量子コンピューティングを不可能にするだろうと考える人もいた。今日では、正確で信頼性の高い
大規模量子コンピュータの構築が途方もない挑戦だということは疑いようがない。しかし、この取り組みを助ける重要なツールがある。それが
この分野に詳しい人々のほとんどが、いつか大規模量子コンピューティングが現実のものになることについて楽観的でいる理由だ。そのツールが量子エラー
訂正だ。次の4回のレッスンでは、量子エラー訂正について
基礎に焦点を当てて議論していく。このレッスンでは、量子エラー訂正を初めて見ていく。最初期の量子
エラー訂正符号の一つである9 qubit Shorコードを含む。そして量子
エラー訂正のもう一つの基本的な概念についても議論する。それはエラーの離散化と呼ばれるものだ。ユニットの後続レッスンでは、より洗練された、そして究極的にはより優れた
量子エラー訂正符号の構成を見ていく。そして、符号化された量子情報に対する量子計算の問題についても議論する。
計算コンポーネント自体が完全ではなく、エラーが起きやすい場合についてだ。ここでレッスンの概要を簡単に紹介しよう。
まず古典的な繰り返し符号について議論する。これはおそらく最もシンプルで基本的なタイプの
古典的エラー訂正符号だ。古典的な繰り返し符号は、古典的な
符号理論の基準ではそれほど優れた符号ではない。少なくとも単独では。でもここではシンプルさを重視していて、特に
考えられる中で最もシンプルな古典的エラー訂正符号を見ていく。それを量子エラー訂正符号の簡単な例の基礎として使う。
その例が9 qubit Shorコードで、詳細に議論していく。
符号自体の説明に加えて、この符号を使ってqubitを符号化する手順、符号化されたqubitのエラーを検出する手順、
そしてそれらのエラーを訂正する手順についても説明する。レッスンの第三部では、エラーの離散化について議論する。これにより、
原理的には連続した可能性を形成するqubitへの任意のエラーについて、離散的な観点から考えることができる。本質的にエラーを
いわゆるビットフリップとフェーズフリップに還元するのだ。量子エラー訂正の技術的な詳細に入る前に、
量子エラー訂正の必要性、そして古典的エラー
訂正の必要性についても少し考えてみる価値がある。レッスンの冒頭で示唆したように、量子コンピュータはエラーに対して非常に脆弱だ。
量子情報の壊れやすさのせいで。特に、環境との不要な相互作用、つまり
言い換えれば世界の残りの部分との相互作用が、量子情報を乱す可能性がある。これらの不要な相互作用はデコヒーレンスを引き起こす可能性があり、情報が
本質的に環境に漏れ出す。それにより量子コンピュータが保持する情報がますます
古典的に振る舞うようになる。また、量子演算は限られた
精度でしか実行できないということを認識することが非常に重要だ。例えば、qubitに特定の量子gate演算を実行したいとする。しかし物理デバイスは
決して完全ではないため、実際に実装されるのはそのgateへの近似にすぎない可能性がある。単一のgateではそれほど大きな問題ではないかもしれないが、
もし何千、何百万もの量子gateを実行しようとしているなら、こうした小さな不正確さが
蓄積し始める。そして計算が終わったとき、期待していた状態とは全く異なる状態になる可能性がある。
これはエラーのかなり異なるソースだが、確かに無視できるものではない。
人々はほぼ一世紀にわたって古典的エラー訂正符号を研究してきた。これらの符号には情報の
伝送と保存を含む多くの応用がある。しかし古典的なコンピューティングコンポーネントは非常に信頼性が高いため、私たちは実際には
古典コンピュータを構築するためにエラー訂正を必要としない。同様に、信頼性の高い大規模量子コンピュータを構築するためにエラー訂正が実際には不要かもしれない。
例えば、トポロジカル量子
コンピューティングの主なアイデアは、システムのトポロジカルな特性のおかげでノイズから本質的に保護された、頑健な量子システムを構築できる可能性があるというものだ。
しかし、これが可能かどうかはわからない。そして、エラー訂正が何らかの形で
大規模量子コンピューティングに不可欠になるだろうと広く信じられている。では、古典的な
繰り返し符号について議論しよう。これは最初の量子エラー訂正符号、9 qubit Shorコードの基礎を形成する。
もうすぐ見ていく。繰り返し符号はエラー訂正符号の非常に基本的な例だ。
アイデアはシンプルで、各ビットを何度か繰り返すことでビットをエラーから守ることができる。特に
3ビット繰り返し符号を見てみよう。ここでは1つのビットを3回繰り返すことで3ビットに符号化する。つまり
0は000として符号化され、1は111として符号化される。もちろん何も問題が起きなければ
2つの可能性を簡単に区別できる。しかしエラーが発生してビットの1つがフリップした場合、例えば
0が1に変わるか1が0に変わるとすると、元のビットが何だったかを
2回現れる2つの2進数値のうちどちらかを見て判断できる。同様に、多数決値を計算することでデコードできる。
言い換えれば、最も頻繁に現れる2進数値だ。そして
最大1つのビットフリップエラーがあれば、デコードは正しくなることは難しくない。もちろん2つのビットがフリップするか
3つ全てのビットがフリップすれば機能しない。デコードしたときに間違った値を得てしまう。それが
すべてのエラー訂正符号が持つ一般的な特性だ。いくつかのエラーは訂正できるが、すべてのエラーを訂正できることはない。最終的には
正確さを保証するのではなく、エラーの可能性を減らすことが目標だ。一般的にそれは
エラーを犯す可能性を減らせる状況の例として、仮想的な受信者に1ビットを
伝達することが目標だとしよう。そのためにビットを送信できるのは
いわゆる二元対称通信路で、送られた各ビットをある確率で独立に反転させる
確率Pとしよう。確率1マイナスPで、受信者は送ろうとしたビットを受け取るが、確率Pで
ビットが反転し、受信者は送ったものと逆の値を受け取る。反復
符号を使わず、単純に目的のビットをそのまま通信路に送ると、受信者は誤ったビットを受け取る確率が
Pになる。一方、送りたいビットをまず3ビット反復符号でエンコードしてから
その3ビットのエンコードを各々通信路に送ると、それぞれが確率Pで反転する。だから
ビット反転の可能性は、1ビットではなく3ビットになるため、リスクは大きくなる
ただし反転するビットが最大1つなら、受信者は正しくデコードできる。エラーが発生するのは
デコード後に2ビット以上が送信中に反転した場合だけで、その確率を計算するのはそれほど難しくない
確率は3 × P²マイナス2 × P³で、Pが1/12より小さい場合に成立する
これにより受信者が誤ったビットを受け取る確率が下がる。この場合もエラーの可能性は残るが
符号がその可能性を減らす。さらに確率を下げたければ、別の符号を使うこともできる
エンコードされたビットをさらに多く繰り返す反復符号も含め、さまざまな選択肢がある
3回以上繰り返す場合だ。Pが1/12より大きい場合には、ちなみにこの符号は
受信者が誤ったビットを受け取る可能性を増やすという意味で、むしろ状況を悪化させる。だからその
状況ではこの符号は使わない。3ビット反復符号は古典的な誤り訂正符号だが、これを
qubitのエラーからの保護に使おうとするとどうなるか考えてみよう。後で見るように、あまり優れたQuantum誤り訂正符号ではない
一部のエラーは訂正できるが、別のエラーをより起こりやすくする。ただし、Shoreの
符号への第一歩ではある。qubitに対してどう機能するか見てみよう。まず明確にしておくと、3ビット反復符号を
qubitに使うというのは、画面に示すようなqubitのエンコードを意味する。Alpha|0⟩+beta|1⟩が
Alpha|000⟩+beta|111⟩としてエンコードされる。言い換えれば標準基底状態が
3回繰り返される。これは量子状態を3回繰り返すこととは違う点に注意してほしい。ある
量子状態sがs⊗s⊗sとしてエンコードされるのとは異なる。これは未知の
量子状態sに対して、no-cloning定理によって実装できないエンコードだ。一方、ここで話している
エンコードは非常に簡単に実装できる。初期化された2つのワークスペースqubitと2つの
controlled-NOT gateを使ったシンプルなQuantum circuitがある。さて、エンコードが
行われた後にエラーが発生したとしよう。特に、Pauli-X演算、つまりビット反転が1つの
qubitに起こったとしよう。この図では中央のqubitだ。もちろんこれだけがエラーの形ではないし、エラーが
この完全なユニタリ演算の形をとるという考えに異論もあるかもしれないが、レッスンの後半で改めて扱う。今は
単なる例として考えてほしい。結果の状態は元のエンコードと同じだが
各|k⟩の中央のビットが反転している。状態の数式からそれは明らかにわかる
ただし3つのqubitしかなく、ビット反転が起きたかもしれないとは思っているが、どのqubitが
影響を受けたかわからないとしよう。ビット反転が起きたかどうかを知る一つの方法は、標準基底測定を行って結果を調べることだ。この場合
Alphaとbetaに依存する確率で|010⟩か|101⟩のいずれかが得られ、どちらの場合も
中央のビットが反転したという結論になる。しかしそれでは元の量子状態が壊れてしまう。この状態は
大切なものかもしれない。結局のところ、目的はこの量子状態を守ることだ。だからこれは良い
選択肢ではない。代わりにできるのは、画面のQuantum circuitを使うことだ。エンコードされた状態を
上の3つのqubitに入力する。circuitが行うのは基本的に、上の2つのqubitおよびエンコードの下の2つのqubitの標準
基底状態のパリティを計算することで、これによりビット反転の
位置が特定できる。この場合、両方のパリティチェックで1が得られ
その情報から中央のビットが他の2つと異なると結論づけられる。それが明らかに反転した
ビットだ。重要なのは、状態が崩壊しないことだ。だからこのビット反転を訂正する機会が得られる
最終的に元の状態をデコードして取り戻せるかもしれない。訂正については
すぐ戻って扱うが、まずビット反転エラーの他の可能性を簡単に見てみよう。ビット反転エラーが
下または左のqubitで起きた場合、下から上に読んで1、0という結果になり、やはり
状態は変わらない。ビット反転が上のqubitで起きた場合、出力は
0、1になり、再び状態は変わらない。ちなみに
ビット反転エラーがまったくなかった場合、測定結果は0、0で、やはり状態は変わらない
これを表の形でまとめよう。最大1つのビット反転から得られる可能性のある各状態、測定
結果（誤り訂正の文脈ではシンドロームと呼ぶ）、そして元の
エンコードを取り戻すために必要な訂正を列挙する。エラーがなければシンドロームは0、0で何もする必要はない
下または左端のqubitでビット反転が起きた場合、シンドロームは1、0で、適切な訂正は
下または左端のqubitにX gateを適用することだ。他の2つのケースも
同様だ。シンドロームに基づいて適切な訂正を適用すれば、元の
エンコードを4つの場合すべてで確実に回復できる。改めて言うが、最大1つのビット反転しか考慮していない
2つまたは3つのビットが反転した場合は正しく機能しない。また他の種類のエラーも
考慮していない。では量子の設定における別の種類のエラーを考えよう。ビット
反転エラーだけを心配すればいいわけではない。例えば位相反転
エラー、略して位相反転も心配する必要がある。Z gateまたは同等にPauli-Zで表される
演算だ。残念ながら3ビット反復符号は位相反転をまったく検出できない。例えば
以前と同様に3ビット繰り返しコードを使ってqubitをエンコードし、真ん中の
qubitにフェーズフリップエラーが発生すると、画面に表示されている状態が得られる。これはまさに、エンコードする前に元のqubitに
フェーズフリップが起きた場合に得られるエンコードと同じだ。だから、エラーを検出しようとして以前と同じ
circuitを実行すると、シンドロームz0が得られ、エラーが発生しなかったと誤って示してしまう。
つまり、3ビット繰り返しコードは最大1つのビットフリップエラーには対応できるが、フェーズフリップエラーの検出には失敗する。
実際にはある意味で状況をさらに悪化させる。なぜなら、フェーズフリップが起き得るqubitが3倍に増えるからだ。
3ビット繰り返しコードはフェーズフリップエラーを完全に無視することがわかった。だから、この種のエラーへの対処にはあまり役立たないように思えるが、
実は3ビット繰り返しコードを修正して、フェーズフリップエラーも検出できるようにすることができる。これがどう実現できるか今から説明する。これが元の
3ビット繰り返しコードでqubitをエンコードするcircuitだ。修正方法はとてもシンプルで、
エンコードの各qubitにHadamard gateを適用するだけだ。Hadamard gateはゼロ状態をプラス状態に、ワン
状態をマイナス状態に変換する。正味の効果として、画面に表示されている状態が得られる。ここでcat
プラス+プラスとcatマイナス-マイナスは、3つのプラス状態または3つのマイナス
状態のテンソル積の省略表記だ。フェーズフリップエラー、言い換えればzgateは、プラス状態をマイナス状態に、マイナス状態を
プラス状態に変換する。だからこのエンコードはフェーズフリップエラーの検出と訂正に役立つ。そのためには、
以前のエラー検出circuitを次のように修正できる。これが以前のcircuitで、やることは
画面に示されているように、最初と最後にHadamard gateを追加するだけだ。
考え方はとてもシンプルだ。最初の3つのHadamard gateがプラスとマイナス状態をゼロと1の状態に戻す。
その後、以前と同じパリティチェックが行われ、2番目のHadamard gateの層がエンコードに
戻してくれる。別の見方をすれば、hatar演算で共役を取ることで、フェーズフリップエラーを
ビットフリップエラーに変換しているということだ。ちなみに、circuitを少し簡略化できる。このcircuitはまったく同等で、
気が向いたら自分で確認できる。エンコードしたqubitをこのcircuitに入れると、フェーズフリップ
エラーが発生していないと仮定して、シンドローム0 0が得られ、フェーズフリップエラーがなかったことを示す。
たとえば一番上のqubitにフェーズフリップエラーがある場合、右端のプラスとマイナスが反転し、
その結果、今回は異なるエラーシンドローム01が得られる。これはビットフリップの場合と同じように
フェーズフリップの場所を特定する。その後、一番上のqubitにzgateを適用して訂正でき、
残り2つのqubitのいずれかにフェーズフリップエラーがある場合も同様だ。だから実際に
このコードを使って最大1つのフェーズフリップエラーを検出・訂正できる。ただし残念ながら、予想通り、
今度はビットフリップエラーを訂正できなくなる。しかし、2つのコードを組み合わせることで
ビットフリップとフェーズフリップ両方のエラーを訂正できるコードが得られるので、まだ希望はある。実際に
単一qubitの任意のエラーを訂正できるようになる。今度は9 qubit Shorコードについて説明する時間だ。これは量子
エラー訂正コードで、今見た2つのコード、つまり3ビット
繰り返しコード（単一ビットフリップエラーの訂正に使える）と、単一フェーズフリップエラーの訂正に使えるその修正版を
組み合わせることで得られる。より正確に言うと、9 qubit Shorコードは2つのコードを連結して得られるコードだ。連結とは、
まず1つのqubitを3つにエンコードする一方のエンコードを適用し、次にその
3つのqubitそれぞれに別のエンコードを適用することを意味する。結果として合計9つのqubitが得られる。これを
circuit図で次のように表せる。まず3ビット繰り返しコードの修正版を適用し、
フェーズフリップエラーを検出する。次に得られた各qubitを独立して元の
3ビット繰り返しコードでエンコードする。このcircuitを少し縮小してスペースを作ると、
元のqubitの2つの標準基底状態がどのようにエンコードされるかを示すことで、コードをやや異なる言葉で
説明できる。これがわかれば、線形性によって任意のqubit状態ベクトルが
どのようにエンコードされるかを決定できる。以上が9 qubit Shorコードだ。一方のコードがフェーズフリップエラーの訂正に使え、
もう一方のコードがビットフリップエラーの訂正に使える。これにより、後で見るように、単一qubitの
任意のエラーを訂正できることが示される。では、9 qubit Shorコードを使ってエラーを検出・訂正する方法を見ていこう。
まずビットフリップエラー、つまりXエラーから始める。これがエンコードを実行するcircuitで、
話しやすくするために、このコードで得られる9つのqubitを3つのqubitからなる3つのブロックに
グループ化して考える。各ブロックは、2番目の
エンコードステップ（通常の3ビット繰り返しコード）を適用して得られるエンコードを表す。これはこの文脈で
インナーコードと呼ばれ、一方、アウターコードは最初のエンコードステップに使われるコードで、この場合は
フェーズフリップエラーに対応する3ビット繰り返しコードの修正版だ。ビットフリップエラーを訂正するには、
各ブロックを独立して扱えばいい。各ブロックは3ビット繰り返しコードを使ったqubitのエンコードで、
そのコードはビットフリップエラーに対して保護している。まず任意のqubitにXエラーが発生したとしよう。
たとえば真ん中のブロックの真ん中のqubitのように。各ブロックを独立してビットフリップエラーがないか調べ、
見つかったエラーを訂正すれば、このエラーは訂正され、元のエンコードが
復元される。実際、複数のXエラーがあってもこの方法で訂正できる。ただし、エラーが
別々のブロックにある場合に限る。単一ブロック内に2つか3つのXエラーがあるとまずいが、
各ブロック内に最大1つのXエラーである限り、インナーコードがそれを検出し、元のエンコードされた
状態を復元できる。だからビットフリップエラーの訂正はこのコードではかなり簡単な問題だ。フェーズフリップエラーも
考慮する必要がある。つまりZエラーだ。今度は何をすべきかすぐにはわからない。なぜならアウターコードが
フェーズフリップエラーを訂正するものだが、インナーコードが邪魔をしているため、直接検出・訂正できないからだ。
ただし、これをどう行うかはすぐに説明する。XエラーとZエラーの仕組みや
量子circuit内での効果をより深く理解するために、これらのエラーとc（シー）の間のいくつかの単純な関係を観察しておくと役立つ。
gateではなく、これは後のレッスンでも役立つ。まずXエラーから始めよう
つまりX gateと、それがC not gateにどう関係するかだ。X gateをC notの
target qubitに適用してからC notを適用すると、順序を入れ替えてC notを先にするのと等価だ
一方、X gateをC notのcontrol qubitに適用してからC notを適用する場合、単純に
順序を入れ替えることはできず、代わりに両方のqubitにX gateを適用しなければならない。これらの関係はすべて
自分で確認できる。標準基底状態に何が起こるかを考えればいい。例えば、Zエラーの場合も似たような状況で
ただしcontrolとtarget qubitの役割が入れ替わる。特に、C notのcontrol qubitに
Z gateを適用してからC notを実行すると、C notの後に
Z gateを実行するのと同じ効果になる。しかしtarget qubitにZ gateを適用した場合は
C notを先に実行してから両方のqubitにZ gateを適用するのと等価だ。そして最後に、これらすべての
関係は対称的で、各等式の両辺のgateの順序を常に入れ替えられるという意味だ
これはX、Z、C not gateがすべて自己逆元であることから、両辺の逆元または共役転置を取るのと等価だ
次に位相反転エラーとその検出・訂正方法を
9 qubit Shorコードを使って考えてみよう。これがencoding circuitだ。引き続き9つの
qubitを3つずつ3ブロックに分けて考える。いずれかのqubitにZエラーが発生したとしよう
ここに示すようなqubitにだ。Z gateとC not gateの関係について今観察したことを使えば
それはC notより前の2つのZエラーと等価だ。1つはcontrolに
もう1つはtarget qubitに。これらのエラーはブロック内の他のC notと可換なので
順序を入れ替えることができ、これが得られる結果だ。下のZエラーはゼロ状態に作用しているため何もしない
残りをずらしてこの図が得られる。つまりわかったことは、中間ブロック内どこかのZエラーは
第2エンコードフェーズの前の中間qubitのZエラーと等価だということだ
同じ推論がどのqubitのZエラーにも当てはまる。ブロック内どのqubitの位相反転も
内部encodingの前の対応するqubitの位相反転と等価だ。これは実はかなり単純で直感的だ
Zエラーが3ビット繰り返しコードにどう影響するかを考えれば。だからZエラーへの対処法の1つは
内部コードをデコードして、外部コードを使ってZエラーを検出・訂正することだ。外部コードはZエラーを訂正できる
3ビット繰り返しコードの変形版だ。これでZエラーが訂正される
望むなら内部コードで再エンコードもできる。また、デコードして再エンコードせずに
いわばその場でZエラーを訂正することもできる。かなり単純なのだが、説明するには
もう少しスペースが必要だ。内部コードをデコードして
外部コードのシンドロームを以前と同じ方法で計算するとしよう。外部コードの3つのqubitだけを使って
再エンコードする。これらのC notを少し単純化できる。実は
先ほど観察したnot gateとC not gateの関係を使うとその助けになる
こうすることで4つのC notを節約でき、これが得られるcircuitだ。qubitの1つにZエラーが発生した場合
シンドロームが今教えてくれるのは、どのqubitがZエラーを経験したかではなく、Zエラーが
どのブロックで発生したかだ。しかしそれで構わない。ブロック内のどのqubitがZエラーを経験しても関係ないことがわかっているからだ
効果はそのブロック内の3つのqubitすべてで同じだ。だからブロック内のどのqubitにZ gateを適用してもZエラーを訂正できる
ところでこれは縮退と呼ばれるものの例だ。エラー訂正
コードにおける縮退で、与えられたエラーを一意に特定しなくても訂正できる。最後に、ビット反転と
位相反転エラーの両方が同じqubitで発生する可能性があるとしよう。例えば
ここにあるこのqubitでビット反転と位相反転エラーが発生したとする。これらのエラーは
完全に独立して検出・訂正できる。実際、各ブロックを
ビット反転を先に訂正してから位相反転を訂正するか、逆の順序で行うかは関係ない。これを確認するために、まず
これらのエラーの順序は関係ないことを観察しよう。望めば入れ替えられる。その理由は
XとZが可換だからではない。なぜならそうではなく、X × Z = -Z × Xだからだ。しかし
-1の因子はグローバル位相なのでこの状況では効果がない。Zエラーを以前と同様に動かせる
この時点で明らかになる。各ブロックをXエラーで先に訂正し、次にZエラーを訂正すれば
両方のエラーが訂正される。あるいは何らかの理由で
Zエラーを先に訂正することにしても、Xエラーはそのプロセスでまったく影響を与えない
それは必ずそうなる。なぜなら第一に、Xエラーは外部コードのシンドロームを計算するcircuit内のすべてのgateと可換だからだ
第二に、訂正のために適用するZ gateとXエラーの順序は
Z gateがエラーだった場合の議論と同様に関係ない。だからZエラーの訂正が可能になり
次に各ブロックを訂正してXエラーを除去できる。つまり主張してきたのは
このコードを使えばXエラー、Zエラー、またはその両方をどのqubitでも訂正できるということだ
実際にはそれ以上のエラーも訂正できる。例えば複数のXエラーも、異なるブロックに分散していれば
あるいは複数のZエラーも、最大1つのブロックで奇数個なら。しかしこれから最も重要になるのは
どのqubitでも1つのXエラー、Zエラー、またはその両方を訂正できるということだ。レッスンの最後のパートでは
これが実際にこのコードがどの1つのqubitでも任意のエラーを訂正できると結論するのに十分であることを見ていく
任意の量子エラーを考えるレッスンの最後のパートに移る前に、
N qubit Shorコードのパフォーマンスを、パウリ行列で表されるエラーがqubitに
ランダムに発生する場合について簡単に考えてみよう。より具体的に、qubitに独立してエラーが発生する
単純なノイズモデルを考えよう。各qubitが確率pでエラーを経験し、異なる
qubit間のエラーに相関がない場合だ。9 qubit Shorコードの最悪のシナリオは、YエラーつまりXエラーとZエラーの両方が
影響を受けた各qubitにエラーが発生し、境界を求めるためにこの最悪のシナリオを仮定する
コードの性能について。ただし、3つのPauliエラーが均等に
起こりうるとも考えられる。さて、Qをエラーから守りたい特定の状態にあるqubitとし、
9 qubit Shorコードを使う選択肢があるとする。使うべきか？答えは必ずしも
イエスではない。なぜなら、ノイズが多すぎる、つまりpが大きすぎる場合、Shorコードを使うと実際に状況が
悪化することがあるからだ。繰り返し符号でpが1/2より大きい場合と同様に。しかしpが十分小さければ、
答えはイエスで、コードを使うべきだ。ではその理由と、pが大きすぎる・小さすぎるとはどういう意味かを見ていこう。
このコードにおいて、Shorコードは単一qubitの任意のPauliエラーを訂正できる。そして最悪の
場合、PauliエラーがYエラーである場合、コードはQを正常に保護する確率は画面に示された式で与えられる。
具体的には、エラーがない場合にコードが機能し、それは
確率(1 - p)^9で起こる。9つのqubitがそれぞれ影響を受けていない必要があるからだ。また、
ちょうど1つのエラーがある場合にも機能する。影響を受ける可能性のある9つの異なるqubitがあることを考慮すると、これは確率9 * P * (1 - p)^8で起こる。
一方、コードを使わない場合、唯一のqubitがエラーの影響を受けない確率は
(1 - P)だ。したがって、コードが役立つのは最初の確率が2番目より大きい場合だけだ。
これらの式は、コードを使う場合と使わない場合の2つのケースにおける成功確率を表している。
小さなpの値に対してこれら2つの関数をプロットすると、損益分岐点が
約3と4分の3パーセントのあたりにあることがわかる。つまりpがこの値より小さければコードは
役立つ。損益分岐点では確率が等しいので、コードを使っても8 qubitとともに時間を無駄にしているだけだ。
しかし、それ以外には害はない。その点を超えると、このコードは絶対に使うべきではない。
なぜなら、エンコードされたqubitのエラーの確率を実際に増加させているからだ。これを一般的に
この文脈では論理qubitと呼ぶ。それは単純に、9 qubit上で2つ以上のエラーが起こる確率が
この範囲のpの値において、単一qubitでの1つのエラーの確率より大きいからだ。3と4分の3パーセントはあまり良く見えないかもしれない。
特に、古典情報における3ビット繰り返し符号の類似した損益分岐点である50%と比べると。
しかし、量子情報を保護するのはより難しい。さらに、この
コードは最初の量子誤り訂正コードとして画期的な発見であり、教育目的には非常に優れているが、実際には
実用的な観点からはそれほど優れたコードではない。これまでXエラーと
Zエラーを9 qubit Shorコードの文脈で考えてきた。次に任意のエラーを考えよう。
まず単一エラーから始める。例えば、そのようなエラーはブロッホ球の非常に小さな
回転に対応する可能性があり、例えば完全ではないgateによって生じるエラーを表しているかもしれない。
あるいは、qubitに対する他の任意のユニタリ操作であり、必ずしも恒等操作に近いものではないかもしれない。
このようなエラーの訂正は難しいように思えるかもしれない。このようなエラーは無限に存在し、
それが正確にどんなエラーかを特定してからそれを元に戻すことは考えられない。しかし
実際には、ビットフリップ、位相フリップ、またはその両方を訂正できる限り、すでに議論したこととは異なることをする必要はない。
実際、単一qubitの任意のユニタリエラーの訂正に成功する。その理由を今から説明しよう。
まず、すべての2×2行列と同様に、任意のユニタリ行列を
単一qubitのエラーを表す行列として、恒等行列を含む4つのPauli行列の線形結合として表すことができる。
ちなみに、お気づきかもしれないが、非恒等Pauli行列を表すために大文字X、Y、Zを使っている。
このシリーズの残りでもそうし続ける。それは量子誤り訂正では慣例的だし、
この文脈では読みやすくもなる。また、特定のqubitユニタリ操作がどのqubitに作用するかを示すために添え字を使うと便利だ。
例えば、Qiskitのqubit番号付け規則を使って
右からqubit 0として始めると、画面に示された式が得られる。
単一qubitに対する様々なユニタリ操作について、各ケースでユニタリ行列を他のすべてのqubitの恒等行列とテンソル積する。
特に、UK、つまりqubit KにUを適用することは、以前と同じ
線形結合として表せる。ただし各Pauli行列はqubit Kに適用される。恒等行列については添え字を気にする必要はない。
ここでの理解は、これがすべての
qubitに対する恒等だということだ。さて、SIIをqubit状態の9 qubitエンコーディングとする。エラーUがqubit kに
作用すると、uk * sが得られる。これをSに作用するPauli操作の線形結合として表すことができる。
恒等の場合はもちろんsのままだ。この時点で、Pauli Yの
行列がI * X * Zに等しいことに注目すると便利だ。そこで式の中でその置き換えができる。
このエラーが発生したとして、今、同じ手順で訂正を試みるとしよう。
最初のステップはシンドロームを計算することだ。Shorコードの場合、8ビット長で、内部コードを使う3回のそれぞれに対して2ビットと
外部コードに対して追加の2ビットがある。しかし実際のところはあまり関係なく、
固定長の文字列として考えるだけでいい。シンドローム測定の直前に得られる状態の説明がここにある。各
シンドロームは対応するPauliエラーから得られる8ビットだ。この時点で、2つの
系が一般に相関していることに注目する。これがすべてを機能させる鍵だ。シンドロームを測定することで
実質的に行うことは、4つのPauli操作のうちの1つが適用された状態に
SIのK番目のqubitに崩壊させることだ。シンドロームからどのPauli操作だったかがわかるので、必要なら訂正できる。
特に、シンドロームを測定して適切な訂正を行うと、
画面に示された形の状態が得られる。重要なのはこれが積状態だということだ。最も重要なのは
右側のテンソル因子として元の損傷していないエンコーディングがあることだ。左側には
ランダムなエラーシンドロームを記述する密度行列sがある。しかし私たちが気にしている系との相関はもうない。
右側の系だ。なぜならエラーはすでに訂正されているからだ。この時点でシンドロームのqubitを捨てるかリセットすることができる。
再び使いたい場合に備えてね。これは実はかなり重要で、ランダム性やエントロピーがどう生まれるかに関わってる
エラーによって生成されたエントロピーがシステムから取り除かれる仕組みで、少なくともユニタリな
エラーに関してはエラーの離散化がこうして機能する。シンドロームを測定することで、本質的にエラーを、
ポーリ行列で記述されるエラーへと射影することになる。任意のユニタリエラーを訂正できるというのは
一見うますぎる話に思えるかもしれない。単独では小さくてほとんど気にならないようなエラーでもね。でも、ここで重要なのは
これが単一のqubitに対するユニタリエラーだということ。コードの設計上、単一のqubit操作は論理qubitの
状態を変えることができない。できることといえば、状態を有効な
符号化の空間の外に追い出すことだけ。でも訂正によって元の場所に戻ってくる。最後に、何が起こるか考えてみよう
任意の、必ずしもユニタリではないエラーが発生した場合。設定は前と同じ
1つのqubitをShoreコードを使って9つに符号化して、qubit channelで表される任意のエラーがこ
そのqubitのどれかで発生する。見ていくと、ほぼ同じように
ユニタリエラーの場合と同様にうまくいく。これを検証する最初のステップは、エラーのクラウス表現を考えることだ
今やれることは、ユニタリエラーと全く同じ推論をたどること。ただし、その推論を
単一のユニタリ行列ではなく、クラウス行列に適用するわけだ
特に、各クラウス行列はポーリ行列の線形結合として表現できる。これにより
このエラーfiが作用するqubit Kに対して、画面上に示されている形でその作用を
表現できる。実際にやってることはクラウス行列をポーリ
行列の線形結合として展開するだけ。エラーシンドロームを計算して測定し、明らかになったエラーを訂正すると、
ユニタリエラーの場合と似た状態が得られる。詳細は省くけど、全部ユニタリの場合と
かなり似ていて、書き下すと少し煩雑になる。でも概念的には
明快だ。これが他の量子誤り訂正符号にも一般化されることを付け加えておく。複数の
qubitのエラーを訂正できる符号も含めてね。そういう場合、複数qubitのエラーはポーリ行列のテンソル積の線形結合として表現できる
対応して、異なるシンドロームの可能性は、単一のqubitだけでなく複数のqubitに対して行われる訂正を記述する
ただし根本的なアイデアは全く同じ。シンドロームを測定することで
エラーを、テンソルで表現される離散的な可能性の集合へと効果的に射影または収束させる
ポーリ行列の積によってね。そのエラー、つまりポーリエラーを訂正することで元の
符号化された状態を回復できる。一方、この過程で生成されたランダム性はシンドロームqubitに移される。それを
破棄またはリセットできる。これが重要なのは、エラーとシンドローム測定によって生成されたエントロピーが
システムから取り除かれる仕組みだから。以上でこのレッスンは終わり。量子誤り訂正を初めて見てきた
9 qubit Shoreコードとエラーの離散化を含めてね。次回も
参加してほしい。次のレッスンではスタビライザー形式主義を扱う。これは記述と
量子誤り訂正符号の大きく興味深いクラスを解析するための強力なツールを提供してくれる。実用的な量子コンピュータの有望な候補も含めてね
それではまた